[Music]
set off on a grand adventure with
pokemon through the sinnoh region
[Music]
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining pearl
[Music]
you'll first travel to a nearby lake
alongside your childhood friend
a pokemon encounter waits for you there
once professor rowan a pokemon
researcher recruits you to complete the
pokedex your adventure begins
this is the sinnoh region
comprised of expansive mountain ranges
grassy fields
bountiful lakes mountain paths and snow
laden trails sinnoh is a land both rich
and rugged in nature
[Music]
various pokemon inhabit the sinnoh
region
depending on the location the pokemon
that appear will differ
in turn-based battles you'll select
moves for your pokemon to use against
opponents you win once your opponent's
hp drops to zero
once the opponent is weakened you can
throw a pokeball for a chance to catch
it
[Music]
battle together with your partner
pokemon and they'll become great allies
you can rely on
[Music]
throughout the sino region you'll have
the chance to battle other pokemon
trainers
[Music]
periodically you'll meet trainers who
will team up with you
[Music]
as you level up your skills you can
challenge each town's gym leader
standing in your way
gym leaders are powerful trainers
specializing in a certain type of
pokemon
[Music]
if you defeat them in battle you'll
receive a gym badge as proof of your
victory
strive to become the strongest pokemon
trainer in the sinnoh region
during your adventure you can enter the
grand underground from the field
the grand underground is a vast
subterranean world beneath the entire
sino region
[Music]
by using a sledgehammer and a pickaxe to
dig into walls
you might unearth valuable items and
pokemon statues
you can also build your very own secret
base
[Music]
there are also places called pokemon
hideaways
here you may encounter uncommon pokemon
living in a variety of habitats
[Music]
put on a show with your pokemon in super
contest shows
dress up in your favorite outfit
dance by tapping along to the rhythm and
appeal to the judges with a contest move
if you're chosen as star of the show
you'll be rewarded with stickers which
can be used to customize your pokeballs
with special effects
the poke etch is a handy gadget for your
travels
the pedometer and the dowsing machine
are just a couple of useful apps on this
device
[Music]
you'll get more apps as you continue
your adventure through the sinner region
[Music]
with local and online play you can
battle and trade pokemon with other
trainers
enjoy connecting with trainers near and
far
[Music]
sinnoh is a land of many myths passed
down through the ages there's also the
mysterious organization team galactic
who's up to some audacious activities
and the legendary pokemon are closely
connected to how your adventure will
unfold
[Music]
there's even more waiting for you in the
sinnoh region
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining pearl available november 19th on
nintendo's switch digital pre-orders are
available now on nintendo eshop
[Music]